You know Margot Robbie and Ryan Gosling,
but what about all those other familiar
faces in "Barbie?" Here's why all those
Barbieland residents look so familiar.
Kate McKinnon is most recognizable as a former
cast member of "Saturday Night Live." Throughout
her tenure on the show, she quickly became one
of the most iconic performers to ever grace
the halls of 30 Rock. Some of McKinnon's "SNL"
highlights include characters like Ms. Rafferty,
a woman recounting her undesirable
encounters with aliens, and Sheila,
a bar patron who gets hot and
heavy with her fellow barflies.
"Hey, was your mother a beaver? Cuz damn - you
got a flat-tail furry face and smell like a lake."
Although McKinnon only recently left "Saturday
Night Live" in 2022, she'd already started
steadily building a film career for herself prior
to leaving, with roles in the 2016 "Ghostbusters"
reboot as well as comedies like "Rough Night,"
"The Spy Who Dumped Me," and "Yesterday."
Given her extensive comedy background, as
well as her penchant for playing strange
characters on "Saturday Night Live," she
was the perfect fit for Weird Barbie,
the outcast Barbie whom little girls play
with too hard. Speaking to Entertainment
Weekly on her visual inspiration for
Weird Barbie, McKinnon commented:
"I just pulled a bunch of pictures
off the internet. I think I typed in,
like, 'effed up doll.'"
In "Barbie," Simu Liu is one of the
more significant Kens in the film,
rivaling Ryan Gosling's Ken for Barbie's attention
and even engaging in an extravagant, '80s-themed
dance battle during the film's climax. For
audiences who aren't aware of Liu's prior work,
they might have been surprised to see this Ken
perform numerous backflips throughout the film,
which no other Ken can replicate. However,
this is all in a day's work for Liu.
Prior to the mainstream success of "Barbie," Liu
was mostly known for appearing in the 2021 Marvel
Cinematic Universe film "Shang-Chi and the Legend
of the Ten Rings," playing the titular martial
artist who is forced to confront his father,
the leader of a vast criminal organization.
"Dad, please. Your family needs you."
Liu notably performed as many of his
own stunts as possible as Shang-Chi,
which was no easy feat to master for
the role. He told Entertainment Weekly:
"I want to sit here and tell you
that I was pretty good at martial
arts before. […] But really, my martial
arts experience was like backflipping
in my backyard when I was a teenager
and doing parkour with my friends."
Aside from his work in the world of Marvel,
Liu also gained notoriety for starring in
the Canadian sitcom "Kim's Convenience"
and also appeared in the 2023 romantic
drama "One True Loves" opposite Phillipa Soo.
However, Liu will likely look back on "Barbie"
as a formative experience in his so-far
short but promising career in Hollywood.
Issa Rae first gained everybody's attention
with her self-produced internet web series
"The Mis-Adventures of Awkward Black Girl,"
which was later adapted into the successful
HBO comedy "Insecure". Created by and starring
Rae, it follows a woman navigating social life,
romance, and contemporary life
for an African-American woman.
"We are not about to be the Black
couple fighting in Rite-Aid."
The series was the recipient of
many Emmy nominations and launched
Rae into the limelight as one of the most
talked-about young creative minds of the 2010s.
"Insecure" concluded its run on HBO in 2021,
but Rae has remained busy ever since. In 2020,
she flexed her acting range with the romantic
drama "The Photograph" and the romantic comedy
"The Lovebirds." On the TV side of things,
Rae has also appeared in various sketches
on HBO's "A Black Lady Sketch Show,"
which she also executive produces,
and hosted "Saturday Night Live" in 2020.
More recently, Rae lent her voice to 2023's
"Spider-Man: Across the Spider-Verse"
as Jessica Drew — aka Spider-Woman.
In "Barbie," Issa Rae plays President
Barbie, who, unlike Margot Robbie's
Stereotypical Barbie, becomes victim to the
Kens' brainwashing after Gosling's Ken takes
over Barbieland. On the film's themes
about womanhood, Rae told Girls United:
"It's really just up to you about how you want
to present and how you want people to see you."
America Ferrera has a unique role in "Barbie"
compared to most other cast members. Rather
than play a resident of Barbieland, Ferrera
plays Gloria, a hard-working mother employed
as a secretary at Mattel whose existential crisis
results in her playing with her daughter's Barbie,
creating a dimensional rift that brings Margot
Robbie's Barbie into the real world. Ferrera
also gets the privilege of delivering
perhaps the best monologue in the film,
ranting to the Barbies about the contradictory
expectations placed on women in the real world.
Though some audiences may be delightfully
surprised by just how much Ferrera steals
the show, true fans of the actress have known
her strengths for years. Her film debut was
in 2002's "Real Women Have Curves,"
which has been regarded by many to be
one of the most influential films of the
2000s for its depiction of Latina women.
"I'm not your baby anymore!"
Since then, Ferrera has starred in "The
Sisterhood of the Traveling Pants" and
its sequel, "The Dry Land", and voices Astrid
in the "How to Train Your Dragon" franchise.
Ferrera's breakthrough, however, came by starring
in the lead role in ABC's "Ugly Betty," centering
on a girl who lacks style but gets employed at a
fashion magazine. After running for four seasons
before getting canceled in 2010, Ferrera then
starred and executive-produced in NBC's sitcom
"Superstore" for six seasons as the floor manager
of a fictional department store called Cloud 9.
In "Barbie," Alexandra Shipp plays
the Nobel Prize-winning Writer Barbie,
who is the first Barbie to be cured of the
brainwashing from the Kens thanks to Gloria's
rant about how unfair the expectations put
on women are. According to the actress,
being a part of Barbie's world was
a dream come true, telling Out about
how walking onto set for the first time
completely overwhelmed her. She said:
"It was so massive and up to scale that
the little girl in me started just crying."
That's high praise from Shipp, who has quite a
stacked resume for such a young up-and-comer in
the world of film. She first gained recognition
portraying the singer Aaliyah in the 2014
Lifetime movie "Aaliyah: The Princess of R&B,"
later making notable appearances in films like
NWA biopic "Straight Outta Compton," LGBTQ+
rom-com "Love, Simon," and coming of age drama
"Dude" throughout the late 2010s. She also
entered the "X-Men" universe as the mutant
Storm in the 2016 film "X-Men: Apocalypse,"
which she reprised in 2019's "Dark Phoenix."
Shipp later received recognition for
appearing in the 2021 musical biopic "tick,
tick... BOOM!," which stars Andrew Garfield
as playwright and composer Jonathan Larson.
Emma Mackey's presence in "Barbie" alongside
Margot Robbie was a long time coming, considering
how much the two actors were told they looked
like each other. In fact, there was meant to be
a joke referencing their similarity in the film,
but Robbie said in an interview with Buzzfeed:
"Once we got all dressed up as our Barbies, we
were kind of like, 'We don't look that similar,'"
However, Mackey still stands
out as Physicist Barbie,
yet another role in her steadily
increasing resume in Hollywood.
Most audiences came to know Mackey through
her role as Maeve in the Netflix series "Sex
Education." Mackey's performance in the show's
second season was notably critically acclaimed,
eventually leading to a rich career
in film, starting with the 2021 French
romance "Eiffel." Mackey also appeared
in the 2022 mystery "Death on the Nile,"
directed by Kenneth Branagh and based on
Agatha Christie's novel of the same name.
Also in 2022, Mackey appeared in "Emily," a
biopic from Frances O'Connor starring Mackey
as writer Emily Brontë, in a performance The New
York Times called "mercurial" and "mesmerizing."
"Charlotte says all the people in the village
call me the 'strange one'. Am I strange?"
The further acclaim Mackey received from
the film eventually led to her winning
the BAFTA Rising Star Award at the British
Academy's 2023 award ceremony. So for those
who enjoyed Mackey's role in "Barbie,"
get used to seeing her in the future.
Kingsley Ben-Adir has had a short yet prosperous
career in Hollywood so far, though his experience
in performing Shakespearean theatre in the early
2010s has made him a tour de force of an actor. He
first rose to mainstream prominence in Seasons
Four and Five of the BBC period drama "Peaky
Blinders," which was followed up by prominent
roles in series like "The OA," "High Fidelity,"
and "The Comey Rule," the latter of which saw
him appear as former President Barack Obama.
In film, he appeared in "One Night
in Miami...," playing Malcolm X.
"Louis X said that if I decide to leave the nation
of Islam, then I would be doing so on my own."
Most recently, Ben-Adir has completely
stolen the show in the latest Marvel
Cinematic Universe series "Secret
Invasion," where he stars as Gravik,
the leader of a group of rebel Skrulls
who seek to take over planet Earth after
growing tired of Nick Fury's failed promise to
find them a new home somewhere in the galaxy.
However, Ben-Adir's role in "Barbie" is a huge
departure from his character in the Marvel
universe. Ben-Adir plays a Ken, and like all the
other Kens, he's desperate for the attention of
Barbies, which coincides with the actor's own
desire to be in the film. As he told Variety:
"It's very rare that a script like that
comes along. So I was like, 'Whatever,
whoever is in it, I just want to be on set with
those guys and I want to be a part of it.'"
If Scott Evans looks recognizable, that may be
because you're mistaking him for his brother,
actor Chris Evans, known for his
performances as Captain America
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe, as well as
films like "Knives Out" and "The Gray Man."
"Ballsy."
Scott stars in "Barbie" as a Ken who fights
for the side of Simu Liu's Ken, while also
having some obnoxious thoughts about finance that
one of the Barbies tricks him into telling her.
Evans' career began on daytime television,
starring in the ABC soap opera "One Life
to Live" as Oliver Fish, a police officer
whose LGBTQ+ storyline caused some on-set
controversy. Evans ended up playing the
role of Oliver for another two years before he
was eventually written out of the show in 2010.
Since then, Evans has had many successful acting
roles, plus a cameo in 2014's "Playing It Cool"
starring his brother Chris. In 2020, Evans
starred in the dramedy "Almost Love". However,
nothing in the actor's career so far has
stacked up to working with Gerwig. He told Out:
"I was in a state of panic the entire time,
just a huge sense of impostor syndrome,
knowing who else was a part of the movie."
Some who went to see "Barbie" may not have
recognized Ncuti Gatwa as Ken, but that
will soon change. The Rwandan-Scottish actor
portrays the goateed Ken who fights alongside
Ryan Gosling's Ken and Kingsley Ben-Adir's
Ken in the Battle of Kens. Like Ben-Adir,
Gatwa got his start in Shakespearean
theatre before coming to wider acclaim
with his role in "Sex Education," which he stars
in alongside "Barbie" co-stars Emma Mackey and
Connor Swindells. He also had an appearance in the
Netflix movie "The Last Letter From Your Lover".
Although his performance as Eric, the
best friend of Otis in "Sex Education",
won Gatwa a BAFTA Scotland Award
for Best Actor in Television,
his breakthrough role is yet to come. In 2022,
it was announced that Gatwa would be succeeding
Jodie Whittaker as the latest incarnation
of The Doctor in the iconic sci-fi series
"Doctor Who." Although he was initially
announced to be the Fourteenth Doctor,
a surprise twist at the end of Whittaker's final
episode showed her Doctor transforming into David
Tennant's version of the character, with Gatwa
clarified to actually be the Fifteenth Doctor.
Gatwa won't make his debut as The Doctor until
a series of anniversary specials in 2023,
before the fourteenth season of
the sci-fi revival debuts in 2024.
Hari Nef is a standout of the "Barbie" cast,
playing the role of Dr. Barbie, who also
moonlights as a DJ for Barbie's Dreamhouse dance
party at the beginning of the movie. However,
the role is far from her first breakthrough, as
Nef has had a groundbreaking career thus far as
both an actress and model. After appearing
on the cover of a 2016 issue of Elle,
Nef made history as the first openly transgender
woman to appear on a mainstream British magazine.
"I like to think that, if, like, my secrets
ever aired I'd be like 'Yeah? What about it?'"
As an actress, Nef first rose to prominence in
the Amazon Prime Video drama "Transparent," which
centers on a family dealing with the revelation
that their patriarch, played by Jeffrey Tambor,
is a trans woman. Nef went on to star in other
popular shows like "You," "The Marvelous Mrs.
Maisel," and most recently in 2023, the
controversial HBO drama series "The Idol".
In the film world, Nef has had many notable
appearances since her breakthrough role in
"Transparent." She has appeared
in 2018’s "Assassination Nation",
the gaming comedy "1Up",
and Peacock's "Meet Cute."
Jamie Demetriou first gained notoriety in
the U.K. as a comedian, appearing in Phoebe
Waller-Bridge's critically-acclaimed
2016 series "Fleabag" as "Bus Rodent."
Although Demetriou doesn't sport Bus Rodent's
horrid teeth in real life, it was a memorable
performance for many, given that the comedian
is now asked to reveal his teeth to strangers.
Since his performance in "Fleabag,"
Demetriou has seen much success in
both the U.K. and across the pond. In 2018, he
created, co-wrote, and starred in the sitcom
"Stath Lets Flats," playing an incompetent
London letting agent. Demetriou's work in
the show netted him a triple win at the BAFTAs
in 2020 for writing, performing, and producing.
His work has remained extensive since "Stath Lets
Flats" ended in 2021. He appeared in Season 1 of
the Apple TV+ mystery "The Afterparty" as
the forgettable Walt, and also appeared in
TBS's "Miracle Workers." In 2023, he wrote and
created a Netflix sketch comedy special titled
"A Whole Lifetime with Jamie Demetriou." In
"Barbie," Demetriou plays second fiddle to
Will Ferrell as the CFO of Mattel — a perfect
fit for Demetriou's awkward style of humor.
Though she's still a teenager, Ariana Greenblatt
has built up an impressive resume. In "Barbie,"
she impressed audiences as Sasha, the daughter
of America Ferrera's Gloria who is disenchanted
by the idea of Barbie and remains critical of
Margot Robbie's character until later having
a change of heart after she sees Barbie slowly
become human. Before that, Greenblatt rose to
prominence on the Disney Channel sitcom "Stuck in
the Middle" co-starring alongside Jenna Ortega.
Greenblatt transitioned to film quickly after
debuting in "Stuck in the Middle," including
appearances in "A Bad Moms Christmas," "Love and
Monsters," and "In the Heights." She even made
her Marvel Cinematic Universe debut in 2018's
"Avengers: Infinity War," playing a younger
version of Gamora during a flashback sequence
in which she's adopted by the Mad Titan, Thanos.
"You're quite the fighter,
Gamora. Come…let me help you."
More recently, Greenblatt has appeared in
two sci-fi thrillers: "Awake," starring Gina
Rodriguez, and 2023's "65" starring Adam Driver,
the latter of which finds the two sharing most of
the screen time as the only humans on a strange,
remote planet that is actually prehistoric Earth.